well today i want to share with you some
masterpieces by i think the lyrical
geniuses of our time that's addison ray
whoever that is again and uh lil na's ex
now i think it's my duty as an
accredited musical critic to steer you
away from some of the some of the you
know really terrible musical pieces of
our day and bring you the real stuff so
i do this for your own good because uh
because i care about you so first up
it's addison ray she's a tic toc
influencer turned pop star
with um
dance moves that may
leave something to be desired i don't
know take a listen now if you follow
this channel you know that i am nothing
if not completely plugged in to pop
culture uh in fact that you know that's
what the kids always say they're always
saying gee whiz that that matt walsh guy
he knows a lot about pop culture
i've heard him say it down at the
skateboard
park um so that's why today i'm going to
review a new joint uh this is hot off
the presses it's a new song from a woman
named addison ray who's a tick tock star
turned
pop singer so she made the jump from
posting 15 second
mindless vapid content to posting
mindless vapid content that's two and a
half minutes long so it's a it's a risky
move it's a risky play we'll see if it
pays off or addison ray's new single
that all the kids are talking about
again is called obsessed that's the name
of the song she posted a couple days ago
he's got millions of views and uh it's
making waves people are excited about it
people are obsessed you might say let's
uh let's give it a watch here it is
[Music]
wanna say something you never said
before
okay now let's um
we'll pause it there for just a minute
we've got addison on a motorcycle there
first of all
now this
in spite of the fact that nobody named
addison has ever actually ridden on a
motorcycle in real life that's that's a
scientific fact but what i really want
to focus on are the lyrics she says
you turned our song down baby what for
you had lit candles on the dashboard
red roses growing out the door want to
say something
you never said before
so
candles on the dashboard
lit candles
on the dashboard of your vehicle how is
that even
possible first of all and why who brings
candles into their car
i can't imagine what would happen if we
were driving along and i pulled out some
candles
and said to my wife hey baby let's uh
let's light these up and set the mood a
little bit she would probably call the
cops is what would happen so i do not
recommend this this is not good this is
not
this is not fire safety this is not
driving safety i do so don't don't don't
take this song that way i'm a little bit
confused already but let's uh let's keep
watching
[Music]
[Music]
when you say that you're obsessed with
me me too okay so a few things to review
here
where to begin uh first thing that
springs to mind for me watching that is
the dancing it is is that i'm not an
expert
is that do we call it good dancing is
that what good dancing looks like
that dancing to me seems mildly terrible
and it makes you appreciate maybe other
pop stars who
can't really sing can't do anything but
they can at least dance when you see a
pop star or wanna be pop star who can't
dance you sort of you realize what
you're missing
this is like the bridesmaid three hours
into the reception after nine glasses of
wine
that's that's like that level of dancing
is what you're getting who am i to judge
i don't know
i don't dance but if i did i would look
like a praying mantis having a seizure
so i guess i can't really judge too much
still you'd expect more from someone who
wants to make a pop song uh was there no
director for this video was there nobody
to stop the camera and uh stop shooting
and say okay hang on addison you listen
um
you look stupid
let's try this again
so they didn't have anyone to do that
but second point is the lyrics okay
lyrics she says we were driving down
sunset
you know i love fast cars
passed by when we first met
damn we made it so far
red eyes from the red light and that
just set the mood
you say you're obsessed with me
so i took a second and said
me too
i'm obsessed with me as much as you
say you die for me i'd die for me too
and if i lost you
i'd still have me i can't lose
would you say that you're obsessed with
me
me too
now i just made that sound better
through my performance i think that it
really deserves
you're obsessed with yourself
that's the message of the song how is
that something
you want to announce to the world that
you're obsessed with yourself
you might as well make a song bragging
about your toe fungus this is like
this is a repulsive trait that you
should not be proud of
can you imagine someone
saying this to you in person maybe like
on a date or something and someone
actually said that to you
but you ask them you know what they're
into what their hobbies are all those
dumb questions you have to ask on a
first date and they say well you know i
like hiking um i'm a big music fan
mainly i like myself uh i'm obsessed
with myself i gotta tell you i am
obsessed with myself
that's called being a narcissist
addison that is not it's and it's not
attractive
it doesn't make you an interesting
person it doesn't make you confident
it makes you seem totally pathetic and
sad i feel sorry for you especially with
the dancing
especially when you're dancing like a
damned tropical bird
on top of saying you're obsessed with
yourself it's pathetic there's nothing
attractive about this at all a few
decades ago private citizens used to be
largely that private what's changed well
the internet think about everything you
browse searched for watched or tweeted
now imagine all of that data being
crawled through collected and aggregated
by third parties into a permanent public
record your record having your private
life exposed for others to see was once
something only celebrities worried about
but an era where everybody is online
everyone is a public figure we're all
kind of celebrities in our own right
keep my data private then i go online i
turn to expressvpn
every time i turn expressvpn on i'm
given a random ip address shared by
other expressvpn customers that makes it
more difficult for third parties to
identify me and harvest my data
the best part is how easy expressvpn is
to use no matter what device you're on
whether it's a phone laptop smart tv
whatever it is all you have to do is tap
one button to get protected it really is
that simple so if like me you believe
that your data is your business secure
yourself with the number one rated vpn
on the market visit
expressvpn.com should get three extra
months for free that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s
welsh go to
expressvpn.comwalsh to learn more that's
what we uh that's what we call music in
this day and age i suppose
this woman who you know has very little
in the way of
singing talent the dancing she looks
like someone's drunk aunt at a wedding
dancing this is like a an auditory hate
crime that we just experienced even
worse yet we have little nazex who not
only consider himself a musician but
also is uh basically a child predator
put to music uh i have to subject you to
this again i'm sorry but take a listen
today we're going to take a look at the
song and video that has caused the stir
in recent days this is montero by lil
nas x you may remember lil nizex he's
the guy who made old town road which is
a quote-unquote country song that sounds
a lot like the rough draft of a real
country song that somebody wrote in 92
seconds on the back of a paper plate
when they were sleep deprived and drunk
what i'm trying to say is that the song
sucks and has always sucked and i tried
to warn people about this when it first
came out but you all wouldn't listen to
me so you made lil nas x rich and famous
as a musician despite his near total
lack of musical talent despite the fact
that he clearly has nothing at all to
say or offer whatsoever now here is the
consequence you did this to yourself
let's um we're not we're not going to
watch that i don't think we can make it
through this whole thing but we're going
to watch as much as we can this is
little nas x
montero let's check it out i caught it
badges today you hit me with a car to
your place
ain't been out in the wall anyway was
hoping i could catch you throwing smiles
in my face
[Music]
[Music]
i'll be on the way
[Music]
okay a couple of thoughts here uh first
of all artistically speaking
the song is trash a lot of very
expensive visuals went into this video
but underneath the glossy packaging is a
song that sounds entirely
indistinguishable from about 50 000
other songs if you heard just the melody
and some of the lyrics you would have no
idea who made the song because it could
have been made by any of about 600
different pop artists this is the
musical equivalent of canned food you
just pull it off the shelf pop it open
here you know and and here's another
song sounds just like this served right
up ah but but hang on hang on you say
see this is different this is totally
unique because whereas normally
these songs are vulgar and sexual this
one is
more vulgar and more sexual you see what
he did there he's a true pioneer this
guy he listened to pop to modern pop
music
and he thought to himself hmm
what if i did exactly that
but made it slightly dumber and cruder a
true moment of artistic inspiration i
mean this kind of moment
kind of moment that michelangelo must
have had when he conceived of the the
sistine chapel
and it was this inspiration that led to
lyrics like and i quote
i want to sell what you're buying i want
to feel on your in hawaii
the man is a poet you can't deny that
and by poet i mean that he has the
writing talent of a sixth grader
scribbling curse words in the back of
his math textbook okay now we're gonna
we're gonna
skip ahead a little bit because i can't
watch this whole damn thing i can feel
my brain
shedding brain cells in protest as we
watch this so we're going to skip ahead
a little bit uh until we get to uh this
part right here watch
[Music]
is
[Music]
call me
[Music]
how do i care if you're
lying to me
[Music]
um
you know i i just i was watching the
video i kept thinking about uh this
article that i just saw
online as scientists announced that um
there's
that there's not going to be any
asteroids to threaten the earth for the
next 100 years there's not going to be
any we don't worry about any
earth destroying asteroids for at least
the next 100 years
and um i watch a video like that and i
think well that is such a disappointment
you know that that's that's devastating
news
because that was our way out it's a damn
asteroid
well now we've been through that once
more together and uh we've suffered the
trauma and we had now we all have ptsd
now hope you learned your lesson which
is never take dance lessons from a
tick-tock influencer